there was a lot of drama
like major major drama
new beginnings emotional endings plus
shocking splits and hookups the
kardashians experienced it all in 2021.
i know
e.t is looking back at the famous
family's whirlwind year kicking it off
with kim who experienced a major shakeup
in february when the mogul filed for
divorce from husband kanye west after
six years of marriage a source told et
at the time that the split was
drama-free adding they haven't been a
couple for quite some time so the filing
is no surprise to kanye kim's family or
anyone else in their inner circle the
two remain a united front as they
co-parent their four children a source
saying kim and kanye's children are
their number one priority and no matter
what will maintain a positive
relationship for them
in 2015 kim opened up to et about the
importance of family support even in the
tough times
i feel like we are so blessed to have
the best support system and the best
family
to really just support each other no
matter what we're going through in
august kim and the kids showed up for
kanye during his donda listening event
in chicago he's done miracles on me
the moment that shocked everyone kim
appearing during the finale to recreate
a scene from her and kanye's nuptials
white wedding gown included kim went
viral again one month later remember
this net gala look
absolutely the head-to-toe black
balenciaga ensemble spurred memes and
even served as inspiration for lizzo's
halloween costume
fast forward to october when kim stole
the show in her saturday night live
debut i mean i'm so used to having 360
million followers watching my every move
i mean how many people watch snow like
10 million tonight is just a chill
intimate night for me
and speaking of snl
now are you gonna kiss me or not
i sure am jasmine
the hookup nobody saw coming funnyman
pete davidson and kim were linked in
november doing dates on both coasts
including a trip to pete's hometown of
staten island and a matching pj night
with mom
a source told e.t that the couple had
been quote connecting on a deeper level
and that pete was constantly making her
laugh
i love that kim and pete weren't the
only love connection driving the
internet wild you guessed it we're
talking about kravis our neighbor and
friend travis barker decided to come
over to chloe's house because his kids
and my kids are really good friends
that's courtney in 2017 before her and
the blink 182 drummer went from being
neighbors to romantic partners this is
such a dream come true it all started in
january when e.t learned that something
had sparked between the longtime friends
not long after there were tattoos not
safe for work videos and steamy pda
posts including this one which court
captioned just like heaven things got
even more heavenly in october when after
nine months of dating travis popped the
question in a romantic proposal in
montecito california i love it back in
2019 court told et dating wasn't a
priority
i don't know i'm just like living life
and
whatever happens happens but i'm not
like thinking about i'm not putting my
energy there but fast forward to 2021
and courtney's whirlwind romance with
travis already has her in wedding
planning mode we are hearing the couple
wants an intimate destination ceremony
and they want it to happen sooner than
later kendall jenner also celebrated a
relationship milestone this year after
going instagram official with her boo
basketball star devin booker on
valentine's day a source told e.t at the
time kendall was ready to take her
relationship with devin to a more public
level and get rid of any unnecessary
speculation in the media and we hear
kenny and her man are going strong devin
quote makes her feel comfortable and
safe and he's super respectful which are
all qualities she loves after first
sparking dating rumors in early 2020
kendall finally set the record straight
during the keeping up reunion in may so
what's happening with you and devin
booker
he's my boyfriend
you're together yeah we also saw the
supermodel share this sweet courtside
pda moment with the phoenix suns player
in october despite her preference to
keep the romance private i think it
makes my life a lot easier and our
relationship a lot
better to be completely honest i just
feel like it's a private matter it's not
really for anybody else to to judge or
know
from hookups to breakups 2021 was the
year chloe and tristan called it quits
after being on again off again since
2019. news of the split came shortly
after the reunion special when chloe
addressed how she and tristan rekindled
their romance amid the pandemic while
co-parenting their daughter true
it seems from social media that the two
of you are back together we weren't for
season 20 we weren't together
and then i don't know we just really
really became
genuine great friends with one another
and great cop he's a great dad and a
good but
co-parenting is not the thing we just
really i don't know it just was this
natural progression and i'm not saying
that's
you know what i would encourage other
people to do it's just what naturally
happened for him and i back in august of
2021 et confirmed the two decided to
split for good a source told et that
tristan and chloe will continue to
co-parent true together in a healthy
loving way it's a beautiful thing to get
along with each other and for your kids
to see that and of course the family is
expanding as kylie prepares for baby
number two in september the makeup mogul
revealed she and travis scott are
expecting their second child together
the emotional announcement featured this
moment when chris got the news
[Music]
[Applause]
kylie and travis welcomed stormy in 2018
after a super secret pregnancy a source
says kylie loves being pregnant and
enjoyed her last pregnancy out of the
public eye she wanted to be able to have
some of that same experience this time
but it was not the best kept secret
another source revealed the plan was
always to give stormy a younger sibling
that this is something kylie and travis
talked about and really planned for i
love it 2021 also marked the end of an
era for the kardashians as their
long-running reality show wrapped after
20 seasons in the finale the stars said
an emotional goodbye we've spent the
last about 15 years
with most of our production
members that are with us every single
day in very intimate situations and
they're
my extended family it's really really
special in my opinion the family marked
the moment with a time capsule filled
with items that reminded them of their
time on the show in total boss fashion
kris jenner included a very special
trademark this is my momager license so
this is when we trademarked the name
momager and you allowed me to be such an
integral part of your business lives and
i'll never forget it in 2020 executive
producer ryan seacrest told et the
decision to end the series wasn't an
easy one this was a very very hard
decision for them to make when you think
about how it started
and where it went and how it evolved no
one would have ever imagined that and so
i think it was an incredible ride and
honestly
that family and that franchise i believe
has changed entertainment forever the
cards already have their next project in
the works
it's never a dull moment in october
chloe hinted on the ellen degeneres show
that the kardashians new hulu series
could be dropping very soon either end
of january
early february fast really fast so
that's the beauty of hulu we're
streaming and we get to have a much
quicker turnaround than previously and
we're really excited we'll be watching
waiting and anticipating what the iconic
family has in store for fans in 2022 and
beyond having a show where we have to
work together we have to
be together i mean i think it just
brings us
closer